receiving her coveted vaccine is the
first bit of good news marlene has had
recently
we're here with your vaccine
she's been feeling poorly and has been
in hospital for three weeks
marlene is recently bereaved losing her
husband
of 55 years to pneumonia
yeah that's it halloween
are you getting better i will in time
wellington you've got to
life goes on
the same is true for warrington hospital
life
must go on it needs to face up to a huge
challenge the nhs waiting list is
growing
and delays in cancer treatment could
have catastrophic consequences
for years to come for waiting
jane is still very sore she's recovering
from surgery
cancer's lumping me kidney and
he had to remove it which was quite
quick
really because of the culverts i think
it was only about
12 12 weeks
jane is grateful her weight for surgery
wasn't longer
the difficulty for dr langdon is to make
sure all
patients are seen as quickly as possible
we certainly know we have a significant
amount of work ahead of us
and every hospital is limited by the
number of theaters they have and the
number of staff members they have
and so we are going to have to change
the way we work is this a legacy of
clothing 19 and the pandemic yes 100
yeah
um it's taken a huge impact even just
stopping just for even a short time
really warrington has been pushed to the
limits
it's coped by repurposing spaces
like its operating theaters it was
crucial that we if we hadn't had this
area
it was full and it was the better area
to be with the right staff the right
skills
and we're moving now into the next phase
which is recovery phase as the
roadmap comes in with the government how
we're going to operate again with the
cancers
that's why warrington's icu is changing
an enhanced care unit is being built
next door
to bring teams closer together the
national health service has had to
change the way it worked in order to
cope with
an unprecedented global health crisis
and some of those
changes will stay with it into the
future
the future of the nhs will include
medical students
like amy obviously at times it's been
very emotionally challenging
uh you obviously seen like the sickest
patients this experience has hopefully
prepared me a little bit for it what
challenges might come in the future
jane is preparing to go home her
experience will help to decide
how this hospital and the national
health service
re-emerges in a post-pandemic world
ashish joshi sky news warrington